what are they sprout these might be
different ones you no let me try
this I tried some and it wasn't very
nice it tastes like
[Music]
tomatoes my name's keeper my name's
Milly what is your favorite snack to eat
fizzy pickles fizzy pickle J what does
that taste like um fizzy pickles and
what's the worst snack to eat um um
Tomatoes I don't like
tomatoes look at my jump it's pink and
white and and mine is blue and blue and
black I like my pink top the best
hi
Grandad do you two want to eat some
snacks
yeah I could already see that have you
had those before yeah and have you had
them before Millie Cooper do you want to
tell Millie what's inside it it there is
I just have to open it
first ham my favorite ham ham and what
else and cheesee and a biscuit I like
the ham you have to put it all together
what do you make a big tower out of it
yeah I got two pieces of cheese double
cheese how does the ham taste CP very
good are you building the tallest Towers
out of this yeah this is how you do
it is that the best sandwich you've ever
had yeah is that better than all the
sandwiches Mommy makes you yep but I
like
my mommy sandwich that she next me this
one on top and
then do you want to try the other one no
thanks what do you think it is tomatoes
tomatoes on sauce it's called Bretta can
you say that
Bretta this one is that my
favorite Big
Bite what don't you like about
it toast FL nice and what do you think
those little red bits are on top
Tomatoes oh tomatoes and
sauces did you just try some tomato yeah
oh which one wins this the Lunchables
yeah um I'll keep this yeah and then put
it somewhere else so you can take it
home
yeah what do you think this is I don't
know a McDonald's Me
Maybe have you ever had this before what
do you think it is I had McDonald's
before this a McDonald's that's from a
place called nandos have you ever been
there m- do you like it Cooper I like
this you don't like it I like
I like this I'm going to eat it all eat
it but what about all the other snacks
it smells not very good what does it
smell of
chicken where do you think in the whole
wide world that chicken comes from
chicken B what does space chickens taste
like um um
[Music]
Tomatoes yeah yeah to my which one's
your favorite this that one gets a
thumbs up yep so what food are you
hoping comes up next giant teddy the
Galaxy how are you going to eat all of
that show me how
you
and I love this one what are they Cow
ice cream Cow ice cream what flavor do
you think that is vanilla
can you open it um
no it's in
wrappers I think this
cold e do you wish you had a strawberry
one now
yeah but I can't have
two what what do you think that is um
PCO
what do you think prco tastes like Val
you me when did you have prco very yummy
at
mon where at mon that mon the
shop I I have one of these at nny je
yeah what flavors does she
have all of them and where do you think
Little Moons come from in the whole
world um from space and how do you think
the little moons are made um made by but
yeah do you think there's butter in
there yeah there's butter in here ew
that one
yumy yeah but it's not for me from s for
me I like this and this I think this
these are bad should we do some more
snacks yeah we
together these both don't look very nice
I don't like these what are they the
that that's brussel sprouts I don't like
brussel sprouts or these you haven't
even tried them yet I did I did try
these big bite I I I tried these I tried
these at many and I didn't like them but
these might
be
you these might be different ones
h
no let me try
this let me
try I this little
bit I tried some and it wasn't very nice
it tastes like
tomatoes both of them AR very nice but
this is glass say called olives and
where in the world do you think they
come from um space which one would you
pick as the winner none of them and I'll
keep it CL for 2
minutes and 2 minutes is up
[Music]
now my
favorite what are these called
Cooper
I saw I saw these on YouTube and they
were
gross do you want some water Cooper yeah
yeah
yeah thanks thank
you I thought you said these were your
have you had these before no
actually they taste like
Tomatoes these taste like tomatoes and
have you tried the ones in the orange
packets they might taste nicer the ones
in the orange packet they might not so I
W they're my favorite crispy orange ones
tell the truth they're my if if I try
one will you try one are they tasty
those ones a little bit bad and a little
bit good so which one of those two is
the winner no I love none and show me
the face you make when you eat
them let's get them away quickly let's
get rid of them I'll close our eyes you
want to save them for later
yeah I want to save
them Chris I'm getting gummies I like
these
come I like this ah
don't eat them
more yumy I like the Cherry sour swe
tast do you reckon they'd be too sour
for us to try those ones would they make
our faces all go funny they would make
them you get sick how can you eat them
all they only make grown sick so you can
eat as many as you want
yeah this is more sour it does it make
your face do that yeah oh give it a go
the go of this one this is not S one
this is s then the monkey
pajamas FL so which one is your favorite
out of those
two both of them both which what about
you
cooper
cooper no no thank
you a
metella on to
toast what's that does that taste like
Nutella yeah
yeah I don't like
Nutella do you know I don't like these
ones but I do like
Mella is a chocolate that one's Nutella
have you ever had that yeah I did and is
it your favorite yep how much Nutella
can you eat
100 go on 1000 show me who can lick the
Nutella off the toast the quickest no
bread yeah oh yeah sorry show me who can
lick the you win this round show me who
can lick the Nutella off the bread
quicker
go who's winning
faster go go
go oh Cooper just you got a little
something on your cheek just there see
if you can wipe it
off no there you go it's gone it's gone
you're
good you got some on your
thumb so is that your favorite food mhm
and where do you you think Nutella comes
from in the
world milk milk so which one is your
favorite I only like the metella ones
the M do you not want to try the Marite
one again show me the face you make when
you eat
Marmite the UK win
yay on the table spinning I don't know
it's never spun before how did you do
that um with our hands oh we are strong
it's a spinning table